if you don't want your mind to go
downhill
should you take a boner pill
can you avoid going senile if your
medication
is penile
these are all words you can hear on law
and order
well experts evaluated data on 7.2
million americans and found that regular
viagra use cuts their chances of getting
an alzheimer's diagnosis within the next
six years by 69 percent yeah and they
all looked at each other and said 69
get it
get it 69.
stupid doctors
jack outy from the university of
tasmania
called the research exciting stuff
and then wondered how the hell he ended
up in tasmania
but then he added at least i'm not in
alaska like that idiot jamie lisa
well do you think this could create more
problems than it solves it's i was
thinking the exact same thing it's like
you know you're like oh my god grandpa
remembered my name but i'm never letting
him hug me again
oh
yikes
yeah i feel like if they discover that
like xanax is also good for heart
disease this will finally explain
everything in my medicine cabinet yes
you know
i kaylee did outnumbered cover this and
what were your talking points yeah you
know we're an all-female show so we talk
about viagra often
i'm 33 i don't know a lot about viagra i
don't know a lot about alzheimer's so i
guess i'll send it back to you jamie oh
this isn't like a game show you can't
pass i
got potato i did just hear that biden
wants to replace his entire cabinet with
viagra
[Applause]
you've never wanted to try it just to
see what would happen
never wait you've tried it no i never
have but i'm curious don't pretend
you're not i
am i knew a woman who uh tried the
female version of it no no no i want to
try the male version of it
and see what it would do
well
you know what's going to happen you know
what you said no you don't it used to be
a hypertension drug so isn't this how
they discover drugs is that they always
they find a side effect that's actually
positive and then they market the side
effect because it's positive they never
invent drugs they just repurpose them
what do you think about drugs is field
research yes cool
like propecia was not even for hair no
it was for like growing it was like i
don't know you're right thanks for
taking us down a dead dead end they were
like
i thought maybe you're gonna add to this
tw saved me from that terrible segue
this is a hard one for me oh
i i you know
the
i get it the the problem with this story
is that you know there are so many
people already you said 7 million yes i
mean 7 million was just the trial yeah
um this is probably good news for a lot
of people i mean yes you know we my only
problem is if this actually works what
if the biden administration starts
forcing people to have oh yeah what if
there's a mandate for viagra if i were
president i would definitely do that
it's probably just a correlation meaning
the people that uh aren't suffering from
alzheimer's might actually be more
sexually active so it's just it's just
like a marker rather than a cause
reminds me of propecia greg yeah
tell me more
i just turned on that same dead end
you know why you have alzheimer's follow
it up
i was wondering why biden gave viagra
the emergency use authorization this
weekend
now i get it that's a wrap yeah that is
don't go away we'll be right back
[Applause]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else